lately witcher training has been one of
the most hotly requested topics on this
channel i've been a little bit reluctant
to cover witcher training though however
because
i didn't know what angle to come at it
from when you look at geralt of rivia
he's basically this supernaturally
enhanced superhuman he's super fast
super strong he's got super reflexes he
can use signs he's got heightened senses
i mean there's only so much we can train
to be like that unlike someone like
batman say who's a little bit more down
to earth
but with some time and reflection i
realized that actually this would be a
perfect topic to cover because the
things that make geralt really stand out
are his connection to nature something
that i've spoken about an awful lot on
this channel and at the same time his
sword fighting which is an angle that i
haven't really covered on this channel
but it lends itself really well to
functional training as we're gonna see
so come with me and let's talk about how
to train like geralt of rivia the white
wolf
[Music]
so yeah speaking of his connection to
nature one of the things i've often
talked about on this channel is how
valuable it is to take your usual
exercises and to perform them outdoors
not only because you're getting the
sunlight the fresh air the cold exposure
or the heat exposure all of which simply
toughen you up but also because you
introduce new vectors more variables
which challenge you more and create a
more dynamic and all-round strength
this can lead to what we sometimes refer
to as farmer strength the example i
always use is doing a pull-up from a
tree branch versus a pull-up from a
pull-up bar on the tree branch you're
gonna have to use your grip to hold on
to the branch harder your hands are
gonna be at slightly different heights
every single time every branch is gonna
be a slightly different width and it's
gonna provide a different amount of give
sometimes it'll bend sometimes it won't
this can then apply to climbing a tree
wrestling climbing a sheer cliff face
much better than simply performing these
same pull-up repetition over and over
again on a straight flat bar the same
thing goes for trail running versus
running now some of you might walk up
this idea and say that it's going to
lead to slower progress because you're
not practicing the exact right movement
pattern and this is true but it's a
trade-off that i think's more than worth
it this is what nikolai bernstein refers
to as repetition without repetition and
he says that this can lead to more
robust movement patterns norman deutsch
author of the brain that changes itself
he uses a great analogy and describes it
like tobogganing down the side of a
mountain you can either take the same
route down the side of the mountain
every single time and dig a deep trench
in the snow you'll be faster and quicker
down that mountain every single time
however if you want to take a slightly
different route it's going to be much
harder if you take a slightly different
route every single time you're going to
that way flatten out more of the snow
you're going to give yourself more
options for how you want to get down if
you want more options in the way you
move you need more varied movement
and now a word from this week's sponsor
morningbrew
so morningbrew is an email newsletter
that provides tech and business news in
an easily digestible manner
this is news that you'll actually read
and it will bring you up to speed with
events relevant to you prior to reading
morning brew over the last few weeks
most of the news i consumed was related
to the next sonic the hedgehog game
which some people would argue isn't
really news at all
now i get to feel more up to date and
grown up in conversation and it's
actually interesting and witty best of
all it only takes five minutes to read
just in the last few days i've been
following the 2022 olympics i read about
sony's acquisition of bungie and i
learned that 2022 is expected to have
the highest number of weddings since
1984.
mornings have been a bit crazy for me
since we had our second child but now i
get five minutes to myself with a coffee
to get up to speed it's like a moment of
calm before the storm that is my day
when my daughter watches rescue bots and
my wife is changing the boy
and there's no reason not to subscribe
really it's completely free and it takes
less than 15 seconds to sign up you'll
then receive the newsletters in your
inbox and you can read them at your
leisure click the link in the
description down below to subscribe to
morning brew today and a huge thanks to
those guys again for supporting the
channel
of course the next question is what kind
of training are we going to be doing out
here when we're in the wild and the
answer to that is we're going to be
using different tools that have an
offset center of gravity such as the
gada i've just got this thing so i'm
brand new at it don't really know what
i'm doing but i've been kettle and club
belling for a while now basically these
tools introduce momentum and torque and
a changing center of gravity all of
which forces your body to battle against
those forces as well as simply moving
the weights themselves this engages the
core a whole lot more and it strengthens
you from different angles
movements such as the cast the gamma
cast or any other circular training
they're not only fantastic forms of
metabolic conditioning they're also
brilliant at training you as a fighter
when you move a weight over your
shoulder
like so you're essentially mimicking
the same movement you perform with a
sword and that's in fact what some of
these tools are used for for training
people to use swords and shields it's
also very similar to throwing someone
over your shoulder which is why it's
been a popular tool for wrestlers so if
we want to sword fight like get out to
rivea then swinging these kinds of
things around is fantastic at the same
time you get to feel like a badass you
look like the white wolf himself
swinging a metal club around your head
or you know you'll look like a complete
lunatic one or the other
if you want to take this even further
introduce even more vectors and
variables then you can also try using
predominantly what are called hybrid
exercises these are exercises that
combine two three even four exercises
movements in a single repetition so as
you're flowing from one movement
straight to the next before you repeat
the thing again an example of this would
be something like a devil press or a man
maker this is fantastic because not only
are you strengthening yourself in
multiple different positions not only
are you sending blood around the body by
training different parts of the body all
at the same time but at the same time
also strengthening the positions between
the movements these are the kind of
awkward angles the things we don't tend
to think of the transitions which is
often where we hurt ourselves in real
life so a fantastic example i'm going to
show you is the kettlebell cross body
clean and press one of my favorite
movements by far as it would happen
someone's left the kettlebell here
in the middle of the woods it's almost
like it was meant to be so
i can demonstrate
let's take my stuff out my pockets
this is an epic movement for a bunch of
reasons first of all you're combining in
here a kind of squat
slight hinge you've got to keep the back
nice and straight as you pick the weight
up off the ground at the same time
you're strengthening the core there's
even a bit of a pull for the lats and
the bicep as you get into that clean
position and there's a press you're
training the shoulders and the triceps
and the pecs to a lesser degree all in
one movement more importantly though
there's also a twist so you're engaging
the obliques and the quadratus lumborum
but it's not just a twist it's a twist
whilst you're hinging and picking
something up off the ground so many of
us train with deadlifts to try and
strengthen ourselves against injuring
our backs when we pick things up off the
floor however you very rarely deadlift
to pick up anything off the ground was
the last time you deadlifted to pick up
a sock more often we pick things up off
the ground with one hand and more often
than not there's some kind of twisting
involved there too
then there's what this kind of training
can do for your brain and this is where
the witcher senses come in because
when you're training out in the wild and
using these unpredictable tools you have
to be far more engaged in what's going
on around you you have to listen to your
body more there are more inputs because
strength and power is not just about
output it's about using your muscle
spindles and your senses to gauge your
angle and then to brace your body and
exert power accordingly
this makes you far more
actively pay attention to what you're
doing which in turn makes it less boring
this increases acetylcholine and
dopamine and it essentially increases
plasticity so that you learn more and
the faster you learn
the quicker those gains come
and to finish with we're going to try
kind of walking hakulau meditation i
should probably explain a little so in a
heckler meditation what you're doing is
you're engaging your peripheral vision
that's your vision
in the periphery of your field of view
on the edges this
changes the way that you're focusing no
longer you focusing on a single thing
instead you're widening your attention
to taking more information this can kind
of hack the brain and put you into a
calmer state of mind apparently this was
used by native americans who called it
allies apparently it's used by
intelligence officers who call it
scatter vision and use it to quickly
scan crowds survivalists also use this
to look out for useful things in their
environment to eat or potential hazards
and
you know geralt loves him some plants of
course you can just meditate sitting
down which is a move straight out of
geralt's playbook it's also a great way
to accelerate the passage of time if you
need to and just being outside in a
beautiful location there's a whole lot
to engage you more anyways i talked
about this a lot in my recent video on
running and the same applies here if
you're in an interesting environment you
become more engaged with what you're
doing
so if you found this video useful
interesting guys what do you think is
this how you imagine geralt might train
let me know in the comments down below
who you'd like to see me tackle next if
you did enjoy this video then please
leave a like and subscribe that would
help me out immensely and if you like
the idea of training for multiple
different skills and abilities not just
looking stronger or moving a bit
stronger then you might enjoy my ebook
and training program super functional
training i'll put a link to that in
description down below of course you
could subscribe if you'd like to see
more like this hit the bell button for
notifications whatever the case thank
you so much for watching this one guys
and i'll see you next time
bye for now